كنت أتساءل إنني قلت ما يحدث
هنا كنت قلقة قليلاً
كنت أتحدث من خلال التعليقات
جيدًا ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك ، إنه لأمر رائع أن
أكون مع رئيس العراق
ومن الواضح أننا نعمل على الكثير من
الأشياء معًا نحن نعمل على
الجيش  نحن نعمل على تنظيم داعش ، فلدينا
مجموعة كاملة من
الأشياء الصعبة للغاية لمناقشتها وبعض الأشياء الإيجابية جدًا
أيضًا
، وكنا أصدقاء
والعلاقة جيدة جدًا
وأريد فقط أن أشكرك كثيرًا
إنها  فرصة مهمة للقاء
الرئيس ترامب للحديث عن
التطورات في منطقتنا
نبدأ الأوقات الصعبة
الأوقات الصعبة وأبحث عن
محادثة مثمرة وصريحة للغاية
مع الرئيس
لدينا علاقة فردية
والولايات المتحدة كانت
شريكًا للعراق
وفي الحرب ضد تنظيم الدولة ، يجب إنجاز هذه المهمة
، وأعتقد أنكم نشارك نفس
المهمة من أجل عراق مستقر ذي
سيادة يعيش في سلام مع
نفسه و  السلام مع جيرانها ،
هذا صحيح ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك ما
هي خطة السفر لنا هنا من
العراق
حسنًا ، نحن نتحدث عن الكثير من
الأشياء المختلفة
وستسمع كل ما نفعله
لكنهم يحبون ما نفعله
ونحن نحبهم ولدينا علاقة جيدة جدًا ،
لا يمكنني التحدث إلا باسم
إدارتي ، ولن أتحدث عن
الإدارات السابقة بصراحة ،
لكن كانت لدينا علاقة جيدة
جدًا ونحن نصل إلى عدد قليل جدًا
.  إعادة التخفيض إلى خمسة آلاف ، لذا فقد
انخفض عددنا إلى رقم منخفض جدًا تاريخيًا
واه سنرى ما سيحدث هل ما زلت
تفكر في فرض عقوبات على العراق
سنرى ما سيحدث لأنه يتعين
علينا القيام بأشياء وفقًا
لشروطنا  الكثير من المصالح المشتركة
هي محاربة استقرار التطرف
في الجوار ،
وهو عراق ذو سيادة ، وهو
أصدقاء مستقرون لجيران وأصدقاء
الولايات
المتحدة ، ونحن أيضًا منخرطون معهم في
أعمالهم النفطية
، وكان هذا دائمًا مهمًا جدًا
من وجهة نظرهم
ومن وجهة نظرنا ، فلدينا الكثير
من الأشياء الإيجابية جدًا لنتحدث عنها ،
لكننا انخفضنا إلى عدد قليل
وكنا هناك منذ فترة طويلة ،
لذا سنقوم باتخاذ القرار ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لكم جميعًا ، شكرًا جزيلاً لكم.
سنعقد مؤتمرًا صحفيًا
اليوم أه لدينا اجتماع آخر
ثم سنعقد
مؤتمرًا صحفيًا بعد ذلك مباشرة ،
لذا سأقول في
غضون 45 دقيقة قبل مغادرتنا.
سنغادر
بعد قليل ، وحققنا نجاحًا هائلاً في دافوس وسنغادر بعد
فترة وجيزة ،
لكننا سنعقد مؤتمرًا صحفيًا مؤتمرًا صحفيًا سريعًا
، ثم نعود
بعضكم إلى  طائرة جميلة جدا
حسنا لذلك سأرى قليلا